[Musique]
alors on salue la planète
on laisse abus salué sans faire de bruit
là on peut le dire
voilà c'est pas le nom de l'émission
ça pourrait être le nom dimension la
planète bonjour la planète mais c'est
tomtom canada en direct de montréal il
est 11 heures 11 minutes heure du savoir
vivre grâce à nos collègues qui se joint
à l'émission sans en avoir l'obligation
semi urbaines bonjour bonjour monsieur
sur internet ce que plaisir est plus
intense encore de l'autre côté parce que
vous êtes vraiment une ressource
importante aux médecins au niveau du
savoir
on va en besoin de vous aujourd'hui
marie claude simard est avec nous avions
tout le monde sait la responsable en
chef bonjour delà de dollars
la section web française de radio-canada
international et les seconds et par léo
gimeno l'équipe latino-américaine
bonjour d où ça va ça va très très bien
alors on me dira pas qui manque
quelqu'un ici dans l'autobus scolaire
mais on a perdu nos étudiants il peut
arriver ce matin
il a passé la nuit chez sa blonde
alors on va ramasser un peu plus loin
alors pour le moment ont des vues
d'ensemble le thème de l'émission 5
image une vidéo
le premier qui pensent avoir la réponse
vous criez au faire entendre autour de
la planète ceux qui sont à la maison au
bureau vous jouez également avec nous
voici les cinq images première chaîne
exactement ils ont deux joueurs de chine
rigoureux vous n'êtes pas dans we go en
en crise en prison oui c'est un con
c'est une école
c'est beau mais on écoles pour
prisonniers non s'échine chine et
peut-être corruption on verra
aujourd'hui c'est puis autorités
auparavant deux buts du canadien ont été
en chine
alors il ya aussi trois détenus en fait
j'en viens de voir qui est accusé de
trafic de 3 trafic de drogue oui le
shérif mère quoi donner à mort cette
semaine il a demandé une révision de sa
peine de 15 ans lui a dit oui d'accord
pas de problème on te condamne à jouer
au lieu de l'amant oui il paraît que ça
se produit dans 10% des cas qu'une
révision à la hausse lorsque quelques
bancs de faire un appel de 7 en chine 2
% des voix pis les deux autres canadiens
bien ils ont été arrêtés pour soupçon de
d'activité c'est très bien alors écoutez
je dis très bien mais ça va très mal
entre le canada et les états unis n'ont
entre le canada et la chine
c'est au sujet d'une histoire
d'arrestation de la mine guendouz c'est
là
la responsable financière de devoir oui
le géant chinois des télécommunications
ça fait un mois et demi que ça dure y
ait cette semaine les choses se sont
intensifiés bonjour excusez le juste une
question d'arrêter ça dans mes multiples
temps je suis vraiment désolé du retard
pas trop le patron était moins il a
toujours cherché à les chantal fontaine
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui donc le thème aujourd'hui
c'est la chine nos prisonniers en chine
et la dégradation nos relations avec la
chine
je voulais vous demander avant que dans
le fond du sujet vous avez tous lu les
journaux vous ne vous êtes pas de besoin
d'être un spécialiste d'information pour
savoir que ça va mal écoutez est ce que
votre je vais lancer l' affaire comme ça
est ce que votre opinion de la chine
comme partenaire économique comme
partenaire de la vie de tous les jours
au plan du commerce au plein dès notre
opinion la chine a beaucoup évolué
depuis quelques temps est-ce que là tout
est revenu et tout est remis en question
en quoi ça va vous paraître un peu
bizarre mais je découvre une chine
agressive avant c'était un peu plus soft
mais l'a par exemple si je vois la
réaction du suisse voit la réaction du
de l'ambassadeur chinois par rapport à
la déclaration de trudeau sur ce rush et
les morgues
il a dit que tout d'un coup le
l'ambassadeur chinois il était très
agressif où il parlait de la réaction de
trudeau comme si c'était de la
suprématie blanche comme si c'était de
du racisme blanc ça c'est vraiment ça je
n'étais pas habitué à écouter ça de la
partie sinon je suis pas spécialiste de
la chine je parle d'expérience
personnelle mais uniquement venant de la
bouche d'un diplomate il a utilisé des
mots des concepts qui sont je
m'attendais pas le même si le parent de
mingora d'où ils disaient que willam on
a respecté les droits de ma fille tout
ça c'est bon mais venant d'un et
j'imagine je redis je suis pas
spécialiste de la chine mais si m
c'est un ambassadeur sperme et ça c'est
à dire qu'ils commencent à tactique
sait on ne dit pas ça il le dit pas à la
légère il c'est sûr qu'il ait ça prouve
aussi la puissance de la chine actuelle
paix il est appuyé par des propos de son
propre ministère des affaires étrangères
qui ollières jeudi alors que
l'ambassadeur s'exprimer là dessus en
entrevue dans une conférence de presse
il avait enchaîné par lot 2 0 comme le
canadien vous devriez cessé de chercher
les appuis internationaux de la part de
pays alliés dans ce débat avec nous non
mais il faut dire qu'on est là en plein
dans les relations diplomatiques dans
les relations internationales qui sont
très souvent empreintes de d'une espèce
de d'hypocrisie si vous voulez mais
alors que on observe une espèce de
tensions entre la chine et le canada on
parle d'amitié de cala métier s'agit-il
si en dessous de la table on se donne on
se donne des cours à ses plaies au
dessus de tout cela mais tient
génération internationale s'est
davantage marqué donc on joue au chat et
à la souris
donc c'est une forme d'hypocrisie qui ne
dit pas son nom mais là c'est frontal un
peu plus donc c'est vrai maintenant
c'est vraiment la face non mais quand on
revient sur les concepts il parle d'
amis mais de quel amitié s'agit-il
questionnable la chine a changé la façon
de les faire avec les autres pays parce
que ici considère on les considérait ça
fait quelques années comme un des
puissances mondiales maintenant c'est
comme la première je suis une puissance
hier plus de toit et gens comme c'est un
pays qui prend sa place
il a plu approuvé là je reviens c'est on
avait déjà remarqué dans le passé que
les chinois n'aiment pas se faire donner
la leçon en terme de
de droits humains alors je pense que ça
les mecs vraiment je me souviens quand
une fois devenu un personnage je pense
un premier ministre de chez nous au
ministre de chinois ta voix puis les
journalistes posent beaucoup de
questions sur les oiseaux mais il y
avait vraiment fait une les accidents en
cloche comprise comme on dit dans le
fond pour eux ce qu'ils disent c'est que
finalement c'est juste que ce qui se
passe donc on m'appelle on peut pas nier
quand même que c'est un crime un grand
criminel en ce moment qui mais c'est le
cas pour de nombreux pays dans le monde
où les droits de l'homme sont bafoués
saoudite
est ce qu'on peut vraiment comparer le
problème qui est en ce moment avec la
chine suit de près avec l'arabie
saoudite s'est complètement que
d'allégations dictatorial où les droits
de l'homme ne sont pas généralement
respecté ses puissants ces pays là ont
tendance à se positionner comme des
démocraties comme moi je serai pas
prêtes à corps à m est-ce que vous parce
que vous vous rappelez de la réaction de
l'ex ministre des affaires étrangères
saoudien à washington après 7 avril a
dit ne nous apprenez pas nos affaires ça
vraiment c'était donnant lecture à sucre
actions comme ça que j'avais à dire tout
le temps les réactions sont là sont des
pays où tout le temps 10 quel vin qu'ils
n'ont pas de leçons à recevoir des
autres nations du monde pelé le contexte
aussi mondiale a beaucoup évolué avec
l'arrivée de monsieur trampo au pouvoir
aux états unis qui lui semble pour le
moment ne pas trop s'intéresser à la
situation dans lequel se trouve le
canada un type les alliés traditionnels
enfin il n'y a pas beaucoup de son sens
par washington ne fait grand chose pour
essayer de dire à la chine de la vraie
cible ici c'est nous donc laissez
laisser faire les canadiens la chine a
pris l'exemple de
de france en plus il fait ça avec tout
le monde ils s'intéressent pas pour les
gens il y est ça ça fait part de nos
affaires puis la chine a eu l'appui des
etats-unis dans la sphère de michael
cocorico on a eu la rencontre de frais
laine de la ministre et de pompes et de
poids exact mais pas trompé ces patrons
qui va s'exprimer là dessus les instrus
même compliqué les choses pour le canada
il ya un mois souvenez-vous il disait
que lui et le ils étaient prêts à
intervenir dans le cas de la dirigeante
de roue et politiquement s'il le fallait
dans ce cadre dans un cadre le jeu
justice étaient prêts à intervenir au
sein de justice américaine le système
judiciaire et de il est censé être
indépendant 1 6 point
au fond il disait à la chez nous à les
raisons c'est tout est politique
ça n'a rien de juridique uniquement la
situation
l'arrestation de ces deux dirigeantes de
huawei au canada une grosse soit pour
ceux qui n'ont pas suivi
l'autre côté de la caméra vraiment ce
qui se passe on va plonger dans le coeur
du sujet en fouillant soin des détails
mais d'abord j'aimerais qu'on a un peu
de plaisir quand même pas ce que c'est
on n'oublie pas les bonnes manières on
parle d'amitié sino canadienne et y en a
ces véritables le suspense comme on les
voit si ça se passait l'an dernier
beaucoup beaucoup de touristes qui sont
venus au canada en provenance de la
chine parce qu'elle est un programme
spécial d'ouverture le canada et voici
ma première question vous allez me dire
combien de points vous risquez de perdre
y en as un 3e à l'émission combien de
points vous risquez de moules de
boulgour essaie de faire notre jeu de la
grosse boule combien pour cette fois-là
ouais ça va des réponses maternelle va
regarder l'émission ça vous regarde
édition sur l'internet et peuple alors
voici parmi les groupes de touristes
étrangers qui visitait le canada en 2018
et nord un peu moins cette année on
pense où se situaient les touristes
chinois en termes d'importance
est-ce que c'était le troisième groupe
de touristes le plus important au canada
sa ca
est-ce que c'était bon le sixième groupe
de touristes le plus important
en nombre au canada l'an dernier où
est-ce que c'était ses s'agissait du 9e
groupe de touristes plus important au
canada l'an dernier on va le faire tour
de table à l'iss le traitement serait le
troisième vous dernier le troisième donc
le neuvième groupe le plus important
tu t'étais troisième temps que la
réponse à la réponse a pas opté pour la
même réponse pour le aaa d'accord moi
aussi aussi parce que sinon il ya
vincent qui perdent des points c'est
quoi une telle est simple si je vous dis
qu'il ya une personne sur quatre qui va
perdre vous me répondre que l'émission
vous n'avez pas perdu 20 boules
il a il est il part à 80 pour le
prochain jeu on parle de déquilibre dans
l'émission on voit si on va bâtir cette
mission grâce à des points de vue très
très différents j'adore guy st jacques
en passe d'enchaîner 2012 à 2016 on a
entendu beaucoup à différentes antennes
depuis quelques semaines voici ce qu'il
a à dire
et donc il faudrait que les finnois
dirigerez ni mousse d où leur colère à
l'endroit des états unis mais tous sont
pris dans ce grand jeu diplomatique
géopolitique c'est plus facile pour la
chaîne de ce texte de s'attaquer à nous
que de s'attaquer aux etats unis ils
sont dans cette période de négociations
intenses qui a commencé de lorsque les
deux présidents se sont rencontrés à
buenos aires et si j'essaie d'utiliser
sur maximum pour régler leurs différends
commerciaux mais entre-temps ils ne
veulent pas comprendre que nous nous
avons les mains liées
il faut
[Musique]
construire les règles établies dans le
traité des flexions et il va falloir
m'expliquer je parle
plusieurs reprises aux chinois ça c'est
le point de vue point de vue officiel du
gouvernement dans l'ensemble n'a même
pas le point de vue majoritaire au
niveau des autorités canadiennes
maintenant l'autre point de vue celui de
la chine
j'ai voulu vous l'apporté l'émission
j'ai demandé à trois reprises à cette
personne de venir à cette émission
il a trouvé de multiples raisons pour ne
pas s'y trouver
c'est bien dommage mais parce qu'on est
capable de forcer la chose on est
capable sont à leur puissance oui non
yves tiberghien professeur à
l'université de la colombie britannique
si le membre émérite de la fondation
asie pacifique du canada
ils boivent souvent vous présenter le
point de vue du gouvernement chinois
avec bien sûr la perspective nord
américaine le voici ce qu'il a à dire
sur les positions canadiennes des
derniers ce truc que mal dans le sens
souhaité des deux côtés tout le monde
est très remonté donc c'est un cycle
action réaction
et puis beaucoup de deux perceptions
mauvaise des deux côtés que beaucoup
d'incompréhension donc c'est le cas de
figure classique qui mêle à des conflits
quoi incompréhension totale et de côté
et du côté chine
ils se trouvent ils sont très fâchés
parce que pour eux c'est pas le droit
international du tout ce qui s'est passé
c'est l'extra territorialité des
sanctions unilatérales américaines sur
l'iran qu'ils y vont au delà des
sanctions internationales et avec des
méthodes très rude il ya aucun autre
pays qui poursuit ses lois nationales
par extraterritorialité en demandant
l'arrestation dans un pays tiers
donc c'est des méthodes très rude donc
c'est assez dur après d'aller dans les
fers en plus la leçon aux chinois on va
vous apprendre le droit international
quand c'est vraiment pas un très bon cas
c'est un cas où il ya plutôt emprunte au
droit international il faut voir que dès
qu'il s'agit de sanctions c'est pas du
droit normal c'est les sanctions c'est
un acte politique c'est la géopolitique
il faut déjà pas aller se vanter que
c'est simplement du droit international
cela dit il ya ensuite il ya un traité
d'extradition entre états unis canada
qui normalement et routine on qu'il ya
plein de cas tout le temps quand il
quelqu'un est en infraction avec la loi
américaine
mais dans ce processus
surtout quand il s'agit sanctions il ya
un passage par la ministre la justice
quand même donc la ministe justice pour
au niveau de l'arrestation devaient
signer puis au niveau de son extradition
devra signer deux donc ce qui s'est
passé c'est que ça a été pris comme un
cadre routine comme tous les autres
alors que c'est alors voilà le
gouvernement canadien
fermez les yeux les yeux c'est ce qu'il
dit et puis le point de vue qu'il donne
au sujet du fait que le canada n'est pas
aussi blancs qui le brillant est
partagée par beaucoup de gens pas
seulement en chine là mais ici même au
canada on le dit on dit on a joué le jeu
des états unis et puis on s'est fait
pincer dans une histoire qui est pas
très clair le canada avait il le choix
ou va-t-il agir autrement hélas sa
ministre de la justice aurait pu décider
en regardant les faits écoutez on peut
faire on peut plus non on peut sans
faire de bruit du renom l'arrêtera pas
parce que ça relève pas du droit
international de l'extra therion
territorialité exactement on allait
faire une lecture c'est une nuance
importante mais canadien a choisi de ne
pas prendre en compte ce pas là et il
était au courant que ça s'en venait il
est avec un fort premier ministre il
était au courant il avait dit que le gt
aux courbes parce que ça faisait
l'annoncé a été faite après une semaine
de l'arrestation de ming ming wang
joutes auxquelles il a dit j'étais au
courant et c'est normal d'être serein et
et ça aurait été étonnant s'il n'était
pas au courant
peut-être que peut-être que nous venons
canadien dormez un peu comme le respect
comme la personne la cour d'uther de
train il a une dormait celui qui à
dormir dernière fois ça à faire mais est
ce que vous comprenez le point de vue de
la chine est ce que font plus qu'un fond
mais une justification est parce qu
éventuellement celle ci chicane la honte
est toujours dennis p se parlent pas ils
se parlent pas nous faudrait peut-être
essayer de montrer qu'on est capable de
comprendre l'autre point de vue il est
n'est pas complètement indéfendable
l'autre point de vue il faut mais à ce
moment mais là le gouvernement canadien
a pris une décision c'est une décision
politique qui leur avaient choisi
on est en train d'assumer les
conséquences d'un choix politique c'est
clair c'est que là ce n'est pas juste
une histoire de droit c'est vrai que
c'est présenté comme une histoire de
droit
je viens pas se poser mon avis mais son
explication les points de vue chinois
il est défendable d'un point de vue
chinois alice vous êtes en jeu zh
vous réfléchissez dans le fond j'ai posé
la question de savoir si le canada avait
trop de choix par rapport à la décision
à prendre n'oublions pas qu'on a eu des
liens particuliers avec les états unis
sur le plan économique notamment et un
moment où il ya différentes sortes
d'entente qui se négocie et avec un
président américain qui se montre
hostile à toute forme de négociation
possible en faveur du canada je me dis
dans un contexte comme celui ci on a
affaire un dossier assez sensible qu'il
faut gérer avec beaucoup de tact et
beaucoup de diplomatie
donc le canada ne risquait pas de se
ramasser avec le problème avec la chine
on l'a dit d'entrée de jeu mais
maintenant est-ce que ce que le canada a
fait ce choix il était contraint ou est
ce qu'il a gagné quelque chose je sais
pas si on a parlé de ça je sais pas ce
que j'écoutais ont je pense qu'on ait
encore des tarifs contre l'acier et
l'aluminium canadien s'est pas réalisé
donc je pense qu'on a gagné récemment
damées et je sais que trudeau et rome se
sont pas là dessus en attaque ils ont
discuté du dossier de way et n'oublions
femmes dans le cadre des relations
internationales il n'ya pas d'amitié
il n'ya que des intérêts mais quand tu
as un gros aux voisins comme tu dois
composer mendier ne soyez pas un polype
agro migrants désolé diplomatique cette
raison que depuis le début de mon
intervention dans cette émission je
parle de diplomatie des relations
internationales c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut prendre avec beaucoup de
pincettes dans la mesure où il n'y a pas
de logique il n'y a pas de clarté il
n'ya que des intérêts
c'est clair ce qui est clair aussi c'est
que cette histoire
l'arrière fond c'est la sphère de huawei
et la de la technologie des appareils
qui pourrait éventuellement contribuer à
créer officiellement qui pourrait
contribuer à la création d'un réseau 5g
au canada mais c'est quoi c'est qu'il
est les rois d'espionnage dans le monde
bat tout le monde est sur tout le monde
sait qu'ils les carnets de l'espionnage
d'allemand et à la russie par tous les
états unis c'est la haine et ça y est ça
fait des années entre et les spins
réciproquement
évidemment aidé c'est qui celui qui
détient la technologie la plus avancée
qui dès qu'ils espions le mieux et le
plus c'est juste en le scénar trempe
avec la chine c'est bon je veux pas que
tu m'inspires comme moi je peux et
espionner à toi oui je vais pas il faut
pas que je te lasses atteindre à ce
niveau technologie mais regardez juste
je reviens à l'arabie saoudite rh au
rejet et quand il était quand ils vont
tuer dans le consulat et ses histoires
qui sont sortis que c'est quoi ça prouve
que le consulat était été ficelé et evil
est partout donc encore une fois
pourquoi comparer la chaîne finalement
amal et armées canadiennes à manger aux
technologies parlant d' espionnage
le gouvernement chinois espère ses
propres citoyens 135 millions de caméras
en chine pour épier les comportements
d'un milliard trois cent cinquante
millions sans fonctionnellement par
rapport à ce qui existe au canada par
exemple ce qu'on n'est pas dans des
proportions non non c'est des caméras
d'espionnage où c'est des caméras de
surveillance et suit ses pas en circuit
fermé aussi fermé que ça sinon on n'y a
pas dit ça fait longtemps qu'ils et
peint toutes les communications
américaines étaient intervenus oui en
fait tout est stocké on peut revenir
très bien alors on va poursuivre avec
notre deuxième jeu de la grosse boule je
tiens à avoir du plaisir à cette
émission qu'on est à son point tous sans
point n'interdit bull civ qui veut
perdre 30 bull
vous avez la main la deuxième question
notre jeu de la grosse boule tout jamais
si vous vous alignez avec la chine
je vais écouter j'allais vous posez la
question au sujet de la chine et de ses
appareils électroniques d'espionnage
mais j'ai changé la chose que ce soit
plus sympathique vous sur la question la
chine fabrique quel pourcentage de tous
les produits électroniques de
consommation courante pas seulement les
produits d'espionnage mais les produits
de consommation courante au plan
électronique elle produit quel
pourcentage de tous les produits de ce
genre dans le monde
voici à aller si vous écoutez bien oui
j'écoute ses 30% d'accor est ce que ces
bébés 55% ou est ce que c'est c'est 85 %
dont je suis tombé par 81 ans pour son
bon
talât fabriquait pas s'agacer lusine
dumontier on peut dire ouais quelque
part elle est là elle est là la main
dans la main 9
oui la main dans l'appareil c'est à dire
que peut-être que tu cliques composants
ne sont pas fabriqués en chine mais
quelque part il ya du produit chinois
dans ses appareils
j'irai au tour de 4 25% autour de 85% du
site l v
si vous répondez c'est très bien samir
j'attends que pour ça aussi atteint 55%
vous dites b je veux développer mais
aussi 80 à 85,6 vous dit que deux
d'entre vous avaient perdu 30 points
lever la main qui êtes vous la réponse
est à 5%
si vous aviez répondu train pour ça en
2012 je voudrais donner la bonne réponse
déjà de 2012 aujourd'hui c'est pas 70 %
à 85 %
ça vous donne une idée ici et pourquoi
ils se fâchent trop en ce moment il va
tout ce qu'on donne raison à tremper si
quelque part pourquoi ce progrès
technologique et si foudroyant ainsi
peut-on comment espace la conception se
fait aux états unis ben ça c'est quelque
chose
bon d'accord je si vous le dites si vous
prenez les appareils qui sont fabriqués
en série conçue aux états unis
recherchent la main d'oeuvre bon marché
où a été transporté dans le marché
asiatique
on peut voir la main de fer la moins
chère possible bon écoute et j'aimerais
avoir vous offrir maintenant un point du
beaucoup moins sympathique à celui de la
chine il était très tendre aujourd'hui
n'est-ce pas alors voici c'est une autre
vue kari lizer collègues maryse jobin en
début de semaine mardi je pense avec
david ben soussan
vous le connaissez oui ils ont parlé de
chine quelque chose comme ça il connaît
beaucoup de choses ce professeur en
sciences université du québec à montréal
je lui ai demandé de participer les
missions et maintenant je suis un avion
c'est dommage parce qu'il a dit c'est
sûrement la prochaine fois
c'est une question mais c'est un prêt de
shimane faire attention
l'économiste on est réalistes en
relation en science politique je pense
multi-talents fait peur aux faire une
vérification au sujet du titre de david
bensoussan parce qu'il va nous dit non
parce que j'ai pas marqué de cette rue
complet alors vous allez ce qu'il nous
dit peut-être à partir de l'emploi ce
qu'ils ont comme c'est moi qui me semble
je sais que vous avez pas le sens commun
et millions de caméras en chine cuivre
de graphie 1.4 milliard de chinois et
qui comptera pas des gentils fiant aux
dépenses de santé certains disent que
cinq minutes sans utiliser absolument
aberrant et donc tout le monde se sent
surveillé le plus il faut pas oublier
que c'est un pays qui est contrôlé par
un parti et que le parti contrôle que le
parti surveille que le parti écoute et
que donc au sein de la population il ya
un certain crainte de parler librement
et de ce point de vue c'est inquiétant
parce que si ce modèle se perpétue et
avec une influence économique et dans
les centres de lachine ça peut se
perpétuer
encore une fois je n'ai pas que ça bras
et ça peut mais si c'est le modèle
chinois qui commence à faire tâche
d'huile un peu partout nous allons
retrouver dans des situations que nous
n'avons pas connu jusqu'à présent
et en même temps cette superpuissance de
la voir sa disposition des moyens
extraordinaires pour il éventuellement
écouter surveiller et déjà on parle non
seulement le vice président américain
même sans parler hockey mais aussi on a
parlé de ceux de certains espionnage qui
apparaît clairement le non respect de
certains brevets et des huiles assuré
internet des banques canadiennes et donc
la question est de savoir simplement si
cette superpuissance peut être utilisé
quand il ya un état de droit écrit un
abus on peut toujours le corriger on
peut toujours faire un procès mais quand
c'est une un état dans lequel le
président j du pilat des pouvoirs
extraordinaires spécialement après bien
des congrès d'octobre 2007 et il est
touchant et dans tous les domaines
politique diplomatique militaire et
cetera mais dès tout même
je sais que ce n'est plus la même chose
je reviens par dans ce bras de fer entre
la chine et le canada est ce que la
chine joue et sa main trop loin d'aller
trop loin
elle aurait pu s'arrêter je ne sais pas
moi dans ses accusations ses reproches
il ya trois semaines et maintenir le cap
sur les arguments évoqués mais là depuis
une dizaine de jours on ajoute les les
les remarques les pratiquement les
insultes et surtout antique tout canada
quoi faire et ne pas faire sur la scène
internationale dans toute cette affaire
je pense que quelque part en dans le
désir de montrer sa puissance ce qui a
pas un risque d'aller trop loin je pense
comme vous que la chine est allé un peu
trop loin
étant donné que les véritables personnes
qui tirent les ficelles de cette affaire
là c'est les états unis ça donc la chine
aurait dû s'adresser aux états unis et
non au canada parce que le problème est
venu d'où la source du problème c'est
les états unis donc je pense que la
chine a trouvé une espèce de stratégie
qui consiste à s'attaquer au maillon
faible de la chaîne mais n'oubliez pas
le canada que la chine en ciel à une
opinion intérieur aussi à une opinion
publique il faut aussi ma c'est
tellement faux pas se faire taper par
par le canada et puis se taire je pense
qu'il ya aussi ce côté communication
pour la consommation interne soit oui et
une tétine emblèmes nationaux est un
joyau un joyau saint-florent verte
écologique
quoique de chaussée ce qui a des
conséquences internationales dans
l'histoire qu'un qui occupent ces deux
pays là
les uns percussions par exemple sur la
perception que pourrait avoir d'autres
pays dans le désir de faire des affaires
mais en tout cas dans cette affaire les
avions sa traditionnelle des alliés
traditionnels du canada se sont
manifestés donc il n'y a pas eu il n'y a
pas eu un chamboulement d'agrément point
de vue je vois que par exemple le canada
était soutenu par l'union européenne par
l'australie par donc ya pas eu je ne
pense pas que ça va faire bouger et
c'est pas c'est pas un mouvement
tectonique que les perceptions ne pas
changer ou ailleurs alex of que la chine
je ne sais pas si elle n'a pas peut-être
que moi je t'ai pas encore mais je vois
que la chine est de passer à une autre
étape 2 de bâti tu d'un peu offensive
comme ça et à passer à l'étape de la
super puissance mais il en fait qu'est
ce qu'on reproche vraiment à la chine en
ce moment on reproche son comportement
par rapport à nos trois prisonniers
c'est ça surtout quand ils disent que
notre système judiciaire et d'enflure
verbal ducotterd la chine qui nous
paraît un peu suspecte enfle au verbe là
pour l'instant là qu est l on l'accuse
d'enfer verbal donc finalement dans les
faits la chine n'ont rien fait vraiment
une des pauses et d'action vraiment
punitive dans le sens qui est pas une
sanction contre canada il n'y a pas eu
de retrait il ya des menaces puis en
fait elle a le droit de traiter ces
plusieurs lieux de cette façon là pour
l'instant le port au prince et ses
propres règles à ne pas lui un très bon
peugeot qu'est peut-être un satisfecit
qui disant que seulement 2% sont mais je
pense que c'est un châtiment qui quitte
en proportion dans ce pays
à la peine oui moi je trouve toujours
quand on critique la chine qu'il faut se
rappeler que le dirigeant le président
de la chine est à la tête d'un point 3
milliards de personnes et si on mettait
justin trudeau qui est maintenant la
tête de 38 millions d'onces à lui
mettait à la tête
posons de trois cent quatre fois plus de
canada peut-être qu'il tournerait un peu
d'écho héron lui aussi se pose en ce
qu'il est d'aider terme d'aidé je sais
pas comment on peut pas diriger la même
façon c'était milliards
ouais je pense qu'il faut qu'on pense
je comprends pas très bien où vous
voulez en venir mais je trouve que avant
de critiquer la chine pour comprendre
qu'on parle d'une entité qui est
complètement différente du canada on
parle de 1.3 milliard de personnes au
lieu d'aller rational sa part à passer
mais ça c'est vrai si tu veux tu peux
pas avoir un pays de deux millions
d'habitants il te prétends duceppe a
refusé l'aide
la biographie jaune si l'on s'appuie
sans plus l'un de ses plus d'un milliard
d'habitants et c'est la plus grande
démocratie
la démographie est un élément de la
puissance d'un pays n'y seront pas le
vatican n'a pas une différence de
quelques millions les états unis et le
même si tu comprends mais jusque là je
comprends pas très bien où il veut en
venir parce que chinois mais si tu qu'on
parle avec les états unis c'est beaucoup
plus les chinois que les états unis
c'est un élément de la puissance d'un
pays c'est pas mais il faut quand même
réfléchir à la fin de cette histoire
comment ça va finir cette histoire ce
qui est ce qui aura un règlement
politique d origine dans cinq minutes
jusque là je veux comprendre
est ce que c'est parce que un pays est
supérieur en nombre en terme de
population qu'on ne devrait pas le
critiquer non je pense qu'il faut pas le
critiquer sur les gestes que je devrais
comme étant d'accord qu'on parle pas de
la même genre de gouvernance
nécessairement que c'est un pays qui
existe depuis de l'ordinaire
quel autre histoire des religions peut
pas parler de pays en développement où
deux pays
vous êtes allé en chine je suis allé en
chine
à l'invitation du président hu a
suffisamment aussi suis allé dans les
études pour ça que je suis allé voir
comment la technologie tchattent de
quelle manière les temps traiter la
chine dans le cadre de cette affaire
non mais je dois souvent notre
conversation est parfaitement bien lancé
mais je trouve ça vraiment génial comme
un jeune stéphane présenter toutes les
côtes et moi j'ai aucune critique à ce
qu'on fait mais souvent on a tendance à
mettre tout les vilains dans un même
paquet puis il ya beaucoup de
différences et beaucoup de différence
mais quand je reviens toujours avec ma
première arguments du début de
l'émission c'est qu'on peut pas comparer
l'arabie saoudite et la chine dans ce
cas ci précisément nous on veut pas
d'eux et non pas juste pour que oui
globalement on ne compare que des
entités qui sont comparables
dans le cas de l'arabie saoudite est de
la chine c'est pas une véritable
comparaison qu'on fait on essaye de
comprendre pourquoi dans cette relation
qu'ont les droits de l'homme ne sont pas
généralement prise en compte avec là je
veux le pas acceptons tamise éclairage
d'accord on t'a mis dehors
vous avez tous vos boules ici pour cent
pour cent de boules la moitié des mais
paul 50 boul et vous y voici
80 bull d'accord très bien alors plus
légers maintenant voici la question
troisième question combien de
prisonniers
c'est très léger 1 c'est tellement
triste pour les prisonniers je pensais à
ça fera tout ce qu'on vous présente
cette question là parce que c'est c'est
très bible alors pardonnez moi pages où
peuvent vous me pardonnez avant si
combien de prisonniers ont été exécutés
en chine en 2016 présent reçu une
sentence de peine de mort comme ce
canadien plus tôt cette semaine comme
les prisonniers ont été exécutés selon
vous en chine en 2016 à présent reçu une
sentence de peine de mort ceux des
chiffres qui pourraient peut-être pas
contribuer ici à la conversation en mer
compréhension de ce qui se passe en
chine
alors nuance en tout cas est ce que ca
de 1400 prisonniers
est ce que ces bébés 567 prisonniers qui
ont été condamnés à mort lente et et qui
ont reçu leur sentence soit exécutée ou
est ce que c'est c'est 154 j'ai même une
vidéo dans un instant vidéo d'exécution
dans cinq dates d'après vous aurais
répondu correctement en 2016 jeux vidéo
avaient déchiré pour dire la même chose
parce que j'ai entendu la représentante
d'amnesty international est intervenu
dans l'émission d'isabelle richy et bien
vous êtes informés merci donc je crois
on était quand même au delà 2005 sans
doute les missions vous diriez quoi
c'est on avoisine les dunes ils ont
avoisiné 2010 mme 2400 ce serait à pour
nous et maintenant 4 3% par rapport à la
population tout ça donc ça me semble
tout le monde soit 154 non ça c'est
l'arabie saoudite
on compare pas été exécutée bébé c'est
cinq cent soixante on parle dès 2016 t
as 2010 sur iphone est un facteur très
important était pas très bien très bien
analysé
maintenant est-ce que vous change pas ma
réponse c'est quoi écoutez on va aller
comparer ça on va les voir ce que ça
donne vous allez tout ce savoir qui a
une réponse je la vidéo
pire un million de caresser la vidéo
numéro 5 la finale est venu au cameroun
on est prêts on regarde ça y'a pas de
son mais c'est le cas j'espère qu'à la
maison on va pouvoir voir des chiffres
en haut là comme jones et la chine
d'accord vous voyez quelque chose là
mais c'est quoi ça sert
2007 on est à mille et quelques minutes
quelques ces 2010 est d'accord donc ça
c'est l'échec de 2007 j'ai un autre
tableau voilà on compare la chine dans
les milliers dit ans en 2016 on estime
que ça pourrait être de 1400 donc la
bonne réponse et à l'arabie saoudite
quand on compare 154 il ira 560 donc
c'est ça contre l'arabie saoudite
on a comparé donc il y as plus de points
non non ce serait bien puis vous c'est
semboules savoir c'est très cher votre
affaire ça conclut cette partie plutôt
sombre de l'émission et vous prêt pour
la partie plaisir qui s'appelle deviner
l'image de la semaine
je sais quel est mon image qui m'a
marquée seule maîtresse et une jeune
femme
ça pourrait être une jeune femme parce
que ça pète deux images
oui ça pourrait deux images commencent
jeunes à côté de l'autre un 2009 et en
oui ça ça va commencer ça fait mais il
ya une sortie plus aussi aux médias aux
états unis en dix ans qui en fait c'est
une soupe ça pourrait être une campagne
de facebook pour améliorer la
densification éducation image faciale
c'est ainsi qu'on s'en va vers la chine
mais non c'est pas la bonne réponse oui
ça se passe en partie à toi c'est quoi
alors
c'est important la ville et la ferme à
quoi bon parler d'elle ou de partout
dans le monde pour ça qu'on sait par
twitter moi je vous avez suivi c'est
trop j'ai subies cette histoire
la maltraitance dans sa famille elle
était en vacances au koweit je pensais
qu'on était dans une chambre d'hôte en
thaïlande et s'enfuir tout ce que vous
en savez des choses on va regarder la
vidéo ici c'est que l'image de la super
belles photos
je pensais pas pourtant on aurait aimé
la voir elle est arrivée au canada en
plein hiver dans sa petite tenue
moi je trouve courageuse parce que
quitter sa famille à 19 ans elle est
vraiment courageuse et très intelligent
que moi j'ai attendu à 22 ans n'a révélé
d'autres il yad'autres saoudienne qui
gisent y en a une qui a 25 ans 24 ou 25
ans je crois pensez vous savez améliorer
les relations mais elle est tellement
elles auront prouvé dans d'autres
problèmes que je vous le dis plutôt que
l'arabie saoudite a été très critique
par rapport à l'accueil qui a été
réservé à sanaa
je suis dans les médias saoudiens
comment est-ce qu'ils vont les andy est
pourquoi les canadiens ne dise pas que
12 % d' il y à plus de 10 à 12% de plus
de filles qui sont qui sont qui sont
boursière saoudien aux à l'étranger soit
donc fait il ya il ya beaucoup de plus
ils se sont attaqués à elle parce que là
dans une de ses photos sur twitter elle
avait un verre de vin ok d'accord
et puis sera aussi publié une photo un
starbucks il y avait du bacon el hadi
khaldi maintenant mais pour une fois
goûté aux plaisirs de variété dans ses
colères la prison se libère et goûtent
au bacon celle de 25 ans mais obligée
légalement obligés d'adhérer
mais ça c'est un peu le côté m'écoute
yayi la réaction dans les médias
saoudiens vraiment il ya eu du bon et
vous aurez le canada est en train
d'échanger beaucoup hein parce que je me
rappelle qu'un je suis venu ici lé
canada c'est comme toujours au milieu il
y avait un problème alors canada et des
syriens y participer pour il y était
toujours comme au milieu de la faire
maintenant on prend position
non mais vivre il faut mentionner que
dans le cadre de cette affaire le canada
n'a pas pris les devants pour dire voilà
je vais l'accueillir
le canada a été sollicité par les
organismes suivi surtout est arrivé là
la mine la l'ambassadrice canadienne
en thaïlande elle était très active à ce
moment là et on sentait que que ça va
aller
on sentait qu'elle allait venir même si
ça on est là on a quand on commence à se
montrer dans le monde et la chine
ils nous tapent pour dire voilà c'est
fait mais ça n'a pas commencé avec le
gouvernement de justin trudeau s'était
même du temps de on a eu des positions
du temps de rappel aussi les
conservateurs avaient aussi des îles et
quand ça va toujours oui mais ils
avaient des positions qu'il a retranché
à l'international ils ont tranché ils se
détachaient d'international
révolutionner vous souvenez pas de ceux
là les compressions tout ça dans les
services et les gens que lorsque justin
trudeau est arrivé au pouvoir il a dit
canada is back au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu mais il ya eu des positions quand
même kelly dans le canada les pas de
rappel des très proches de m
l'israélien yossi américain ian kelly
c'était très minimes écoutez on refait
pas l'histoire aujourd'hui nous si la
future qui nous intéresse
voilà c'est tout pour cette semaine le
présenteront la semaine prochaine j'ai
déjà une idée du terme on peut jouer au
jeu du 5e match déjà si vous voulez on
peut placer la prochaine mission même
jeu renfort impose ici l'autobus
scolaire s'arrête on salue la planète
persie prochaine
[Musique]